all right my awesome jacket arrives you
see it yet well if you haven't seen it
this is the it spoiler talk which is
pretty much gonna be me talking about
penny wise there's a lot to talk about
penny wine and that is a spoiler warning
if you haven't seen it you should really
go see it see it if you want to see the
spoiler free reveal I do have that I put
a link below if you just want to hear me
talk about spoilers and do not care
welcome so that's your spoiler warning
in the end
okay so penny wise penny wise isn't
really penny wise penny wise is a
construct of a clown that was called
penny wise but in the end it is
essentially a boggart from Harry Potter
he's a creature that takes the form of
anything someone fears and he makes them
scared shitless because he feeds on the
fear the fear makes the person taste
better I guess
however we are in the muggle world so
there's no ridiculous spell you can't
just laugh in the way you see your fear
embodied in physical form you just run
and hope you're faster than it and at a
point in the movie you realize that
penny wise or it is an apex predator and
it has been around for a very long time
it comes around every 27 years or so and
then goes back into hibernation comes
back 27 years later kills a bunch of
people by taking the form of what they
fear no matter what it is and then goes
back into slumber so you can very much
assess that it is very good at what it
does which is scarier because I still
don't know what it is I'm about 350
pages into the book so I don't know what
it is I do know that there's a scene
where the bully in the movie he dies
from zombies because this movie takes
place in the 80s whereas the it novel
when they're kids takes place in the
late 50s and in the late 80s teenage
boys were not watching Creature from the
Black Lagoon so they had a bunch of
zombies kill him rather than The
Creature from the Black Lagoon but in
the book when The Creature from the
Black Lagoon kills the bully he
literally is The Creature from the Black
Lagoon the entire time there's no clown
there's no Pennywise just comes up to
him and he pulls his head off like a
daisy just which makes me think why is
penny wise in the movie so much and
maybe because in the miniseries with Tim
Curry penny wise became very popular
you need to put a consistent face with
your villain or maybe penny wise is in
the book more and I just haven't gotten
to those segments there were a couple of
people earlier on in the book they both
saw the clown but maybe their fears were
clowns was Georgie scared of a clown I
don't know but he was a clown when he
killed him in the book and he was a
clown in this movie I'm just spitballing
here so if you know the answer from the
book don't tell me don't ruin it it is
I'll read the book I'll find out but for
right now these are the questions I have
I like when you find out the history of
dairy you see that circus and there's a
who looks a lot like young penny wise
and I imagine that little kid grew up to
be penny wise the dancing clown and did
it see hims like yeah you know what I'm
gonna take the form of you that's a
great form to take if I'm not turning
into other things that's gonna be my
baseline not a bad one cuz it's a creepy
ass clown it does make sense that the
longer this story goes on they start
seeing penny wise instead of other [ __ ]
the unrealistic thing is penny wise is
terrorizing these kids and there's still
mostly afraid of something else after
that slide projectors scene which has
got to be the scariest thing they have
seen in their lives I imagine they would
only ever see penny wise after that
that's what the Boggart would turn into
forever and the whole fear thing and the
fact that penny wise has to get someone
so afraid for their life before he eats
them there's something about a horror
movie a scary movie a movie in general
with a villain or the antagonist is just
messing with someone you're like dude
just kill them but it's all to get the
friend time to save the good guy then
they get out of there in this movie it
made more sense he has to get someone so
afraid for their life before he eats I
do feel like that scene in the house
though he was scared enough you could
eat but when it captures Beverly and
takes her down to its lair I'll go after
her and I love that same because it
being the bogger it starts turning into
things that they all fear when it faces
them tried to eat Stanley's face and he
became that weird creepy ass [ __ ]
painting he hates that's when you really
see it is not really a ghost it's not a
spirit it's a life form of some sort but
I think that's scarier that's one of the
many things that sets it apart at this
point in my life I haven't seen anything
that makes me think yet demonic
hauntings are possible but I do have
things that I fear myself if there's
something out there a life form that can
take on the form of that how do you run
away from that that's just something
else entirely we all have fears so a
little bit of it does exist in our
brains and our subconscious so when it
takes Beverly at the end it doesn't kill
her because she's not afraid of it she
has seen an experience darker [ __ ] than
the rest of the kids in the movie so
she's like I yeah you're a clown that's
all you got and the thing she's afraid
of most she kicked in the balls and
smashed over the head so penny wise
doesn't have much over her squeeze just
puts her in some weird comatose state
where she just trips balls and is awoken
with a kiss
scigirl IVA that was so classic fairy
tale that that actually went over to the
cheesy side of the forest doesn't
compromise the movie as a whole is just
saying funny enough the one scene
I was like blow this a bit too extreme
even for me it's the rock fight scenes
the rocks like as big as my fist the
whole time I'm like oh just covering
your mouth you could lose some teeth I'm
that boring adults that they're like
that is so dangerous they're taking
rocks to the head and face I would love
to see that scenario but actually like
real rocks smashing to everyone's faces
and they'll have concussions and they
all die that would really be I imagine
in the next movie bill skarsgård is
going to be Pennywise the clown still I
feel like that's very important we're
gonna have new actors playing these
characters 27 years later they all come
back to dairy because Pennywise has come
back and they made that oath and while
they're all older Pennywise the exact
same age how do you fight something like
that it transcends life as we know it
that's really cool at that point you got
to think to yourself who's going to play
them as adults that's gonna be half the
fun for the next couple years or at
least one year or at least a month
before we find out the cast Jake
Gyllenhaal Joseph gordon-levitt Amy
Adams who's gonna be an itch chapter two
and he gotta think if it's 27 years
after the events of this movie the next
movies gonna take place in 2015 or 16 in
which case do they not have social media
did none of them keep in contact via
Facebook are they all gonna show up in
the next movie like what are you up to
Wow crazy I had no idea cuz I do not use
social media in 2015 my guys will find
out I met a bunch of people tweeting me
like why didn't you give it awesome
tacular I don't know if you wanted to be
awesome too I suppose it could be I'll
bump it up I'll say it is awesome
tacular
here's the part we all realize if I did
that or didn't do that the world would
be no different whatever it's a great
movie alright guys so it I imagine
you've seen it so I'm going to ask you
this what would it turn into to freak
you out before it kills you what do you
fear most me who turn into the bumble
from Rudolph would blow my mind if I saw
that thing walking towards me but
whatever it would turn into whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]